cinéma avec la sortie cette semaine de
la première surproduction père
production hollywoodienne sur les
attentats du 11-septembre world trade
center c'est son nom le film est signé
oliver stone
il raconte l'histoire vraie de deux
policiers sauvé après 8 heures sous les
décombres des tours
pascal deschamps vincent bonfanti on n'a
qu'un but en septembre le policier john
mc laughlin est appelée ou actuels
center avec ces hommes dont une jeune
recrue où ils diminuent quelques temps
plus tard la tour numéro 1 s'effondre
prisonnier des gravats quelques mètres
l'un de l'autre mc laughlin et du manioc
seront extraits des décombres plusieurs
heures après le film reconstitue aussi
minutieusement que possible le calvaire
des deux hommes dont le témoignage a
nourri le scénario au sol et en turquie
de quatre jours dans les décombres comme
l'un autour d'une personne au dessus du
trou assez tôt ce jour là mais elle est
partie et n'est jamais revenu au score
alors qu'on de maryse nous ont
découverts à nouveau six ou huit heures
après will les a suppliés en hurlant de
ne pas nous avons attendu seuls vingt
personnes ont été retrouvées vivantes ce
jour là oliver sim a tenu à tourner la
scène avec de nombreux pompiers
policiers présents le 11 septembre et
qui ont participé au sauvetage de jane
et mouillé quand on m'a sorti de là
d'abord j'étais heureux d'avoir survécu
humaine mais tout de suite après j'ai
levé les yeux et je n'ai pas vu les
tours j'ai demandé où sont elles
on a répondu il ya plus rien montils
soit au grand qu'eads certains ont
reproché oliver stone de s'en être tenu
à l'anecdote
bref avoir abordé l'événement par le
petit bout de la lorgnette
c'est un film très important toile et
leur plainte en cas ces témoins ne
seront plus avec nous quand nous
souvenir seront dépassés par l'événement
était tellement leur église et
politiquement on finira par oublier le
jour lui même et pour les enfants
d'alors ce film sera un document
cet art
ce sont d'ailleurs les deux policiers
qui en ont assuré la promotion le plus
souvent à l'étranger comme si tel était
le visage que les buttes voulait donner
de l'événement et celui là seul le
visage de ces survivants